So now, we wrote
down the momentum
of the system of our
rocket at time, t,
and the movement of the
system of the rocket at time
t plus delta t.
Let's make some
simplifications in our notation
just to make our calculations
a little more easy to read.
So the first thing
we want to do is
we want to say that the
mass of the rocket at time,
t-- this is the
mass of the rocket
plus the mass of the fuel
in the rocket at time, t.
We're just going to
denote that by mr.
And keep in mind that, when
you write the mass at time
t plus delta t, we'll write
that as the mass at time
t plus delta mr. This
is precisely how you
define a differential.
Even if this
quantity is negative,
you always write the difference.
m of r of t plus delta t
minus m of rt equal to delta
mr. That's how we write
a differential delta
mass of the rocket.
So the mass of the
rocket at time, t,
looks simpler-- m
of r plus delta mr.
So those are two ways of
simplifying our expressions
for the terms that are
appearing here and there.
Now, the next thing was, recall
from our mass conservation,
that we had the condition
that delta m fuel was
equal to minus delta m rocket.
So now, we'll take those
two simplifications,
and now we'll write down our
system momentum at time, t.
That's very simple.
mr v of r at time t, and
we'll now write the momentum
at time t plus delta t.
Well, we have the
first piece, which
is mr plus delta mr times
the velocity of the rocket
at time t plus delta t.
Now, be careful
here because we're
going to use our conservation
of mass condition
to replace delta m fuel
with minus delta m rocket,
and we'll use our expression
for the velocity of fuel
in the ground frame
of the rocket.
So we have minus delta m
rocket times the velocity u
plus v of r of t plus delta t.
And this simplification, we'll
write equations 1 and equation
2, will enable us to apply
the momentum principle
in a very transparent way.
And that's what we'll do next.